[Musique]
l'échelle est ce que vous voyez quelque
chose se passe est allé lècher rehab on
top
vous allez on faisait beaucoup d'eau
est-ce que vous êtes prêts 3 olé
pourquoi je vous ai demandé de mettre
des bandeaux fallait pas que vous voyez
les numéros que vous avez dans le dos
vous allez tous me donnait un numéro et
le numéro que vous désignerez jeu le
pousserait à l'eau à la fin il y en aura
à qui sera sauvé et laura magnifique
cadeau ça sera actif en ma compagnie
caroline tu me désigne quel numéro le 3e
3 3 le 3
[Musique]
elle s'est désigné mais attention
kelly mais de venir vous destiniez
cannes le 11 mai au nom des neuf espèces
numéro un pourquoi tu aimerais que ce
soit qui ici j pourquoi parce qu'il est
con merci non mais l'autre là le numéro
un à un les cherry hill et de ce côté là
regardez bien devant la mairie si tu es
mokhtar mokhtar tu enlève ton t-shirt tu
es éliminé
allez on m'a demandé à jean-michel
numéro 7 devrait voir qui tombé dans
l'eau la jama les animaux changent pas
j'ai dit ce que je disais mon benji il a
trouvé mon numéro
[Musique]
jean castanet justement numéro 5 non
plus que quelque chose à dire atteindre
au titulaire tu passes à côté du beau
cadeau vous n'êtes plus que ça et il ya
toujours
hamiani samedi justement tu dessines
camion vient désigne du mouron
on a 12 euros le numéro 9 ali
malheureusement je n'ai que le numéro
date
kelly beethoven y désignent quel numéro
11 ans mais apparemment kaelin tempah
kaehlin t'aime pas c'était déçu que ce
soit jean michel
vous n'êtes plus qu'à 3 benjamin
castaldi jean michel mais réalise hamoud
benjamin il reste six le 4e 8 tu désigne
quoi 8
6 4 au mythique clip tu es sûre du 6 tu
prends est utile change le 8è tu prends
le 6 n'ont pu s'évader boîte entre le 6
le 8 et le cad tu prends le situe à
plélo 8,7 au delà des mots tu veux
changer encore sa portée alors que tu
vaux bordel cas benjamin une fois plus
tu n'a vraiment pas de chance
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça j'en mets ici autour de journée
puisque ces barèmes désire lever tout le
6 je vais dire 2-6 2-6 qu'on met à l'eau
c'est sympa où le cisco garde le [ __ ]
le sis à l'eau je vais courir de là bas
et je vais jeter celui qui perd l'animal
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean-mi tu vas venir me rejoindre mon
chéri tu vas partir en ma compagnie
faire du shopping
une séance de shopping en ville avec
votre carte bleue oui je choisirais ce
que voudrait il y aura plein de cadeaux
c'est là que ça va être plus compliqué
c'est vous allez devoir choisir un
accompagnons et quelqu'un qui vous avez
envie de faire plier bagage maxime non
pourquoi j'aime pas ça gueule très
bientôt
oui
car au nom pourquoi on va nous emmerder
d'accord alice amon oui ah oui vous
aimez bien moi j'aime bien gilles non
pourquoi il a été parfait tout ça va
être chaud khédive et novelli oui
d'accord
monta non ceux qui ont été éliminés à
les rejoindre vos chambres et regarder
inspecteur barnaby sur ses vitres veux
tu va maintenant d'éliminer deux
castaldi oui ou non
jd qu'au nom voulait nous ralentir
alyssa bonne bon j'ai dit non parce que
j'ai envie de garder qui met donc kelly
et castaldi donc idée qu allissa von
vous allez voir barre de vie dans votre
chambre
merci
jean michel tu sais quoi je vais partir
je vais te laisser et tu viendras avec
celui que tu voudras ce sera pour moi
une surprise
ou peut-être une déception jean-michel
je te laisse face à ta responsabilité
[Musique]
moi ma vie ma vie c'était d'échouer
toujours à sa durée du vol
m